Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the
'Try Not To Smile' challenge.
Now, it's been a while since I did one of *these*
...and since that time I've turned my heart into a...
stone-cold
stone-cold ice cube
stone-cold ice cube of death.
All joy has been purged from me
in every way possible!
And I have no smiles left...
...for anybody. T~T
It's #smilenever up in this bitch.
I've got a few, uh...
"cute" and, uh...
...and , uh, nice videos to see here
nice videos to see here.
but I won't be swayed by their adorable nature!
I'm a stone-cold bitch
and that's what I shall stay, so...
Bring it on ya...
*thinks for a word*
Honkin' dog.
REPORTER:  -has caused a ruckus!
The pup has been seen around *laughs* town doing this!
*reporter breaks into tears laughing*
REPORTER2: THAT. IS. HILARIOUS *also laughing*
*Both rofling*
REPORTER2: The paws...
-breaks into laughter-
Nope!
No smiles here.
Why would there be any?
VIDEO: Guy: No one needs me here to be *tbhdb*
Guy: Why did you keep saying here?
Guy: There's no one that needs me here to be *tbhdb*
*massive regret*
Guy: There's no need for me to be here *tbhdb*
Girl: *laughter*
Guy: There's no need for me to be *tbhdb*
Girl: Alright. There's no need...
Guy: There's no need...
Girl: ...for me to be...
Guy: ...for moi for me
*laughter*
Mark: *ahem*
Mark: Nope.
Girl: There's no need...
Guy: There's no need...
Girl: ...for me to be...
Guy: ...for moi for me to b-
*laughter*
*Markigrunts*
Girl: Okay, "There's no need for me to be here today."
Guy: No needs for me here for to be *tbhdb*.
Girl: *laughing*
What the FUCK is wrong with me?
Guy: No need for me here *tbhdb*
*stops* I can't fucking say it!
*both laughing*
Guy: There's no need for me here tebid-
Ughhhh!
How could I ever have a job?
Go in there in work-
"There no need for me here to be today!"
*Mark trying to swallow his smile*
*denial mmm*
NAH! It's a trick!
It was all a trick!
TRIIIIIICK!
Shane: Look, if you did, just say so.
recorder: *laughs histerically*
Shane: Do it now... I need to know.
Recorder: *laughing*
Lori: A minute?
Recorder: *laughs with the weirdest sounds*
Recorder: *still laughing weirdly*
Shane: Alright then.
Recorder: *laughing histerically*
*Recorder loses his shit*
*Mark stone-cold heart cracks a bit*
*Mark begins to strain*
*Recorder loses his shit*
*Mark loses it with a squished face*
*Recorder calms down*
Andrea: Give up our guns?
WOOOOO!!
*The Markiengine roars*
No.
*cough cough*
This one has somehow turned out to be more of a
"Try Not to Laugh"
than it has
"Try Not to Smile"
which makes it even
HARDER!
Because at least in the "Try Not to Laugh"
I can smile a bit!
Maybe.
Recorder: Mum! Mum! Quick!
Mum! QUICK!
Recorder: Quick!
Mum: Whut?
*Camerawoman begins wheezing in laughter*
Mum: What the hell is this?
*fanning the saran wrap*
Recorder: *Still wheezing*
Mum: ?????
Recorder: *Laughing like a stalled engine*
*Goes again, sounding like a teapot*
Recorder: What you do-
Mum: What are you doing?
Recorder: *More Wheezy Laughter*
Mum: Oh for goodness sake!
Mum: Did you put it on the toilet next?
Recorder: *laughing*
Not-
*fumbles*
It's-it-it's not even supposed to be not funny!
It's not "smile-worthy."
It's depressing, even.
That's horrible.
Sarcastiplier: You could have killed her.
Sarcastiplier: I'm so concerned!
Woman: What does "y e s" spell?
Man: Yes
Woman: What does "e y e s" spell?
*Begins laughing*
Woman: What does "E. Y. E. S." spell?
Man: eeYes?
Woman: *Starts losing it*
Man: What is happening?
Woman: *Loses it again*
Woman: What does "y e s" spell?
Man: yes.
Woman: What does "e y e s" spell?
Man: EE-yes
Woman: *Dying laughing*
Man: Why are you crying for?
Woman: What does-
*stops from laughter*
Man: What are you do-
Woman: Okay, try again.
What is "y e s" spell?
Man: Yes
Woman: What does e - *laughs* "e y e s" spell?
*Engine starts laughing*
Man: Ease?
Man: Ay es?
Man: You're making me-
Woman: I CAN'T BREATHE!
Woman: *tries to calm down* Okay.
Man: E Y
Woman: *But fails*
Man: E Y E S
EeeeYES?
*both laugh*
Man: *slow* E..
Woman: *Hysterical giggling*
"y"... "e"...
*sudden realisation*
Man: Eyes
Woman: *Goes insane*
Man: *Laughs along*
*tries to hold laughter*
*ponders life*
Oh boy. A good, old-fashioned social experiment.
Recorder: -ing pictures of people that we find beautiful.
Woman- Aww.
Recorder: So...
Recorder: is it okay-
Recorder 2: We were wondering if we could take a picture of you?
Woman: You may.
Recorder: Thank you. You ready?
Smile!
*Markigrunt*
*Markigrunt (×2)*
My stone-cold heart.
Recorder: Taking pictures of people who we find beautiful
STONE-COLD HEART!
THIS GODDAMN SOCIAL EXPERIMENT!
Recorder: Taking pictures of people who we find beautiful.
Girl: Oh!
*look at each other like wtf*
Mark: Aw, they look at each other.
Girl 2: Um...
Recorder: No you don't.
Girl: You look good! You look good.
Recorder: You ready?
Recorder: Just smile. Ready?
1... 2.. 3.
Recorder: -pictures of people we find beautiful.
Woman: OH MY GOOOSH!
Thank you so much!
Recorder: We're taking pictures of people that we find beautiful.
Guy: Thanks guys.
Recorder: 2 3
Mark: UGH!
This has been done before, but GOD it's
pure.
Recorder: We're taking pictures of people that we find beautiful.
Pure Bullshit!
Recorder: we're taking pictures of people who we find beautiful.
Girl: AWWW!
Recorder: So we were wondering if we could take a picture.
Recorder: Alright, ready?
1... 2.. 3.
*Dramatic Markimunk*
*breathes pure cute*
*growls as his heart melts*
Girl: *joyful squee*
This is me NOT SMILING!
AHHHH
Inspirational bullshit, that's all it is.
It's pandering for views.
That's all it is!
It's all staged.
*breathe in*
yeeEEEEE
(Mark tries and fails to fight the cute)
VIDEO: *guitar strumming with babies dancing along*
YOU- FUCK YOU BABIES!!
YA AIN'T GONNA MAKE ME SMILE!!!
VIDEO: *guitar strumming with babies dancing along*
VIDEO: Dad: Daisy, what's your christmas wish?
Daisy: I wish that Luna was a real puppy.
Daisy: AWwwWWW (rip headphone users)
Daisy: MUMMY! MUMMY!
Mom: This is Luna.
Daisy: MUMMY!
MUMMY!
Daisy: *cries*
Mark: I WANNA BELIEVE THIS WAS STAGED!
Daisy: (still crying) He's so cuteeee.
*Jurassic Mark Roar*
I KNOW THIS IS WEIRD FACE TO MAKE AS REACTION TO THIS OCCURRENCE
BUT AAAAAAHHHHH!!!
Dad: C'mon give her a cuddle and a kiss.
Mom: What do you think of her, dear?
Daisy: I love her.
*Markigrowl drowning out the video*
Fuck! I'm not crying!
This is my sweat from straining!
Not a real dog.
The only thing, like if I ever want to not...
Like, if I ever want to lose a competition to cry or something like that
all I got to do is watch those videos of the dogs
Uh... th- their owner has like come back from war or something like that.
That's all I got to do.
(get mark to do a challenge of try not to cry! C:)
I watch one of those and I'm gone.
Alright, so that was to try not to smile challenge.
We had a bit spattering all over the place with like...
Try not to...
Try not to LAUGH and Try Not To Cry.
This was like a...
an experience.
It was a good, old, like
Try Not to BE Human in front of all these human experiences.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed this one.
I don't know how often I'll do these types of... this one.
But there's another subreddit, uh... that i want to explore that uh... I think is gonna be good.
I've got an idea for it.
But I'll-I'll see that in the future so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-Bye!